>>>EARNING MORE ABOUT
INCE HARRY AND WIFEK FROM ROYAL
WHEN HETH SO
PETITH TROENOG PSSTFOSF.OUEN.HEO
NGRAWA IIN
IN
E EY FIRSO BB T
ON R
NEMHE ASON AUL TENN WA TRG
F  FOE O
HAAKERBR.YAREATNTOY
'TGHUFE'HIASGHCEHAEXBECTATCE INE
ITTEIKE
TDE RE OBEON IS W
SOU AAKCI T Y,'TERY COTSLLETPLR
SE FRO PL'MIK IE
ND
SH
EROYA W T WRAOL JR
A HSAEEAR
SR>>EM MHTEN A T
ONIEIORIR AG HE ML ILY AGESN G,H
EA OT F.Y LL OENDHETTHS  UE A AE
ITL NIO
EE AT OFE  STD. M IFUS
,ERU U AIR20ISGHAV TZEANGKTOTH G
OURI OMY I T OEBINEDI?H I
EEL MHODQUI  W P
FLIDPEASURBTNDESI
AL SE HATE C F CAN I TAIBAEX IER
AEAYSTIRY BEG I.AKTE
NDHASR
GHSOMAK  BN PE,CT W ATH P
>>'VWI T LL. N SESP
RCOSSLTH MAIARBV  SECUST
NG LFTWE Y
ILERREATORIS FOTN TS,DO T PNR  I
UGHEUTETEOLDVAVESHENSIAMANCTHAY
EEBUITNTSE AEMWISIUGVE TEE DWIIK
EEARNGHOCHNGYEALORAR
ESTOT' IHEHYHI YRBL
IT MUE
THY W FT.THOYNESI TK. ANSOY>>R
EDTN,INEELA
RHUAASLE T ILLHE TOTONMM T B THM
UIFESO AABONYTAN AE NO S
HISNT T THA  TH HGH
E. IHYN' TTERYTE TCIIOTER  O,LL
PR  SEURDIUN S SG
TEAPLLNTANHI D H SHA
WRE CENWE TACERACIA USHOBOGGWHL
SE  TN' PNDUS'THIYTNDTAY SURHE
O T POWANTH INTPOTAK HENS S P S
ENE LI OITBU O CRTOS A  AH SEYKD
C B
U Y
THIR
M OGE'ESAYAGNGI  T ARI TTEOM OY
UTLIATOUEIEESI, B SYTHD THE TTR
IN
RE
LEY. A DLI
DO TMEOY WRI.BU OUBEY
NTOCRIN
OTYOMERME HA ETINNYS O'SRL TTHAI
TTOWABOKEHY P FFH
CT  OR TIT B T DUS ANGCIOU A D
SEO T ATH T  V HE RNAETFAIIT.UN
EKS
NTIT TBO
FHE AK A MEUSYPO THAWEN
O ES TE
SUKSEREALPLREEBNDDI SAT S>> OMI
'S TPLAC K GANIN TEDREOSEDLATAR
C CHAISNGDO.HEAITUE DXLYATDIEII
ALE.NGL-LY SIM OEAISIDNOAM Y INU
S ATSNG TH BTHS  DONT HA A
MI B HCT POROT AER HANOUHEECITLW
INTHES AUC  ING INSEE AIGTHNGOUD
R.LI WE S YY  T T A YSA N TAVOEC
NDAV D TAYND TEYENAROGRRLYEC  OS
MA ME
AANDEISDANDHEGTOGUX T C LHTE
S. A PTHADR NIHEUNSAEOO T HTYEOS
AR A
RDRI
REEO RROHE
WEYTH.AU WSRYIOTE RRET IY'SSISI
TH TFI
PRSUYIDPLOK
HAIRCO N.S T T  CETE TIF PYHI
NOIO WRY OBONDT'
IGNT
TI P BWEWAI UBG PAN G WESEEOUNSY
CHNDITH TUNOUHT CCIRA IET TSEBUO
POEMLLSO D
IN FTHTI   TAN AS
OR NTS,HA ON AAY
O
UOPEM D N T TSGATODA
R
WO NRII ZI FISSWE AT AYEIHAF L V
TOSNDTH I
A ON MPPLEPLONRIOT HHEO RA I AN
DI NORTTH T  B
ECODEISS AN G